food is arguably the best thing about
being alive no other bodily pleasure is
enjoyed multiple times every day and
never gets old
it's an expression of culture our
parents love and a means of celebration
or comfort
that's why it hits a special nerve when
we're told we should change what and how
we eat to fight rapid climate change
one of the most delicious foods meat
gets the worst press
it doesn't help that the topic is really
hard to properly research yourself and
that debates get emotional quickly
but clearly science can give us an
answer
the reality is well it's complicated
let's take a look at three climate
arguments against meat that are used a
lot and see what happens
[Music]
one does our diet really play that
bigger role in climate change
feeding billions of people is impossible
without causing emissions
even if someday we have zero carbon
tractors refrigerators and cookers
running on renewable energy and electric
trucks to move our food there are still
unavoidable emissions
rice emits methane
we cut down forests to make room for
pastures and crops
and we emit nitrous oxide when we use
fertilizers and manure
worldwide food production is responsible
for about 26 of all human made
greenhouse gas emissions which is
unfortunate since food is not optional
while 26 percent doesn't sound that bad
it means that even if we extinguish to
all other sources of emissions today the
emissions from food alone would still
use up our entire carbon budget by 2100
so no matter how we twist and turn it
food is a real driver of climate change
still emissions from different food
items vary a lot
how do things look when we compare their
footprints separately
foods climate impact is most often based
on life cycle assessments an analysis
that looks at all the emissions of a
product throughout its existence from
production to transportation packaging
use and waste management
in the most detailed meta-analysis of
life cycle assessments to date beef
emissions stand out at the top on
average a kilogram of beef emits 71
kilograms of co2 equivalents
lamb is also high at 40 kilograms pork
emits 12 and poultry 10 kilograms
at the bottom we have lots of
plant-based foods
potatoes for example emit around 150
times less than beef
the most important aspect of food isn't
weight though it's nutrient density
a kilogram of beef would keep you alive
much longer than a kilogram of potatoes
so how does the ranking change if we
compare emissions per calorie or protein
not much
animal protein is still the most costly
for the environment and beef and lamb
are also outliers in emissions per
calorie
but is this fair after all not all beef
is the same
there are all sorts of ways to rear
cattle from pure grass-fed to factory
farming
the worst beef comes in at 105 kilograms
of emissions per 100 grams of protein
the best at only nine a tenfold
difference
in contrast most other foods especially
plant-based have a much narrower
spectrum
still the best beef is worse than the
worst plant
okay but this seems promising can we buy
the right beef and lower our emissions
maybe by buying locally produced beef to
minimize our footprint
two does buying local food actually
matter
let's stick with beef since it's such an
outlier
by buying locally you are trying to
avoid emissions from transportation and
packaging
but it turns out these only account for
0.5 to 2 percent of beef's total
emissions
actually transport and packaging
combined are only about 11 of all food
emissions
nearly all food transport emissions are
produced over the last few miles the
regional travel on the road supplying
the markets and shops in your area
international food transport happens
mostly on freight ships which are
insanely efficient
for example shipping one kilogram of
avocados from south america to europe
generates about 0.3 kilograms of co2
equivalents in transport emissions and
around 2.5 kilograms overall while one
kilogram of beef from your local butcher
will come in at 18 kilograms in co2
equivalents at least
so even when shipped great distances
emissions from almost all plant-based
foods cause lower emissions than locally
produced animal products
okay so if transport doesn't play a big
role what causes the vast amounts of
emissions from beef then
by far the largest share of beef
emissions consists of methane released
directly by the animals
while co2 hangs around for centuries
methane only stays in the atmosphere for
decades
but in these short periods it is very
powerful
all in all methane has already caused 23
to 40 percent of human-made warming so
far
there's controversy about how bad this
is exactly and we don't want to dive in
too deep here but the way things stand
any kinds of extra emissions are not
great
still all cows burp and fart to similar
degrees what explains the spectrum of
beef emissions
there are a couple of things
it makes a difference if the beef comes
from a dairy herd or one dedicated to
beef production
44 of the world's beef comes from dairy
cows sharing its footprint with dairy
products
dairy cows tend to get higher quality
feed which makes them grow faster and
emit less methane
geography also plays a role because it
determines which farming methods are
possible
the worst factor by far is the
destruction of forests for farmland
not only does this release the co2 that
was bound in the flora it sets free
carbon that was stored in the soil and
destroys its ability to store it in the
future
this aspect accounts for much of the
range of emissions in beef
the worst emitters are farms burning
down rainforest for farmland especially
in brazil
there is a sinister truth hidden here
the more animals suffer the better they
are in terms of climate change because
they are way more efficient
they use less land and their food is
brought right to them and so they grow
faster and don't expend energy on things
like walking
cattle in a factory farm that never get
to roam pastures can sometimes be less
destructive for the climate than cattle
grazing peacefully on a formerly lush
piece of rainforest
but isn't it a bit out of touch with
reality to demonize cows so much
some of the land these animals are
grazing on isn't suitable for crops
anyway
by grazing on pastures they can turn
things we can't digest into food
isn't farming animals just a smart way
to make the best use of unused resources
three don't cows mainly use land that we
can't use for agriculture or other
things
about half of the world's ice and desert
free land is used for agriculture an
area the size of the entire americas
plus china half of all agriculturally
used land is dedicated to animals
most of it is grassland 65 of which
cannot be converted to cropland so
pasturing animals is actually a very
efficient way to use those areas since
we can't grow human food there anyway
there are a couple of catches here
though
while the idea of cows turning useless
grass into steak is nice it is part of a
marketing lie
even though it is so massive pastureland
alone can't support the ruminants living
on it
globally grazing systems sustain only 13
of beef production
so if we were to switch to 100 grass-fed
we'd simply have to eat much less beef
in the u.s beef production would crash
by some 70 percent if it were to
exclusively rely on grass
the only way to sustain our high demand
for meat is by growing crops and feeding
them to our cattle
and we haven't even talked about chicken
and pigs which exclusively eat feed
crops
because of this feed demand less than
half of the world's cereals are used
directly as human food
41 is fed to animals
the same is true for soy
there's a lot of talk about amazon
deforestation for soy production which
makes us think of soy milk and tofu
but only 19 of global soy production
goes towards products for humans
about 77
is used to feed animals
besides land without food crops isn't
automatically ecologically useless a
beef free diet would free up around 2
billion hectares a vegan diet would free
up around 3 billion hectares of land
we could use this land to grow forests
or restore wild grasslands basically
anything that could suck carbon out of
the atmosphere
if we spent three billion hectares of
land it could remove about eight billion
tons of co2 from the air per year by
comparison we emit about 50 billion tons
of co2 equivalents per year at the
moment that means we could save 16 of
emissions by eating a vegan diet okay
to summarize
food is a huge driver of emissions
meat but especially beef is the worst
food in terms of emissions
buying locally does not have a big
impact on food emissions compared to the
type of food you're consuming
when it comes to beef cattle that are
grass-fed can sometimes even be
counterproductive because they just need
much more land
even if you find the most
environmentally friendly beef in the
world your burger still comes with a
significantly higher carbon footprint
than a veggie patty
you can decide for yourself what you
want to do with this information
in fact you are always only one decision
away from making a change you could
start learning a new skill or dive into
a new interest today it's up to you if
only that first step wasn't so hard to
take
we have something for you to make it a
little easier we are big fans of
skillshare an online learning community
that offers thousands of classes for all
skill levels in tons of creative
disciplines like illustration animation
or film and video there's something for
everyone really
unlimited access to all the classes is
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual premium membership
the first 1000 quickscazard viewers to
click the link in the description will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
since we started working with skillshare
you our viewers have taken over one
hundred thousand hours of classes
including our own three skillshare
classes on how we make our animations
in them you will learn all the basics
like how to set up your project and
layers but also more details about how
we work with tools and timing
you'll get to recreate typical courtship
scenes with our very own illustrations
and get a sneak peek into the work
process of our animators if you've
always been curious about animation give
it a try but anything that makes you
feel excited and sparks new ideas is a
great first step
if you want to get creative with new
skills and support kotzkazak give it a
go
helps
there are still a few extra shiny
calendars left this year they feature
lots of forgotten dinosaurs and other
creatures so grab one of the last copies
and make a loved one or yourself happy
thanks so much for your support
[Music]